let's go with Lucario and like always
we're gonna go ahead and crank up the
intensity to 5.0 once we've done all the
characters we're gonna have to go back
and try and actually get a nine point
nine on one of these me and I hate this
stage right here it's so weird like how
it like that is this just a huge gap
that you can fall in over there on the
right
I played Lucario a little bit in Super
Smash Brothers Brawl right where am I
crazy whichever one he was in I played
him a little bit oh wow
nice attack right there are they
fighting each other are they teaming cuz
I haven't seen them fight each other at
all they just keep running over here
what game is this stage from I don't
even know Xenoblade maybe I don't know
that I don't recognize that character
Portero is that thing a Pokemon the
character I'm playing with yeah
Lucario is a Pokemon I have no idea
which generation he's from I mentioned
earlier I know like I know the Djinn one
Pokemon really well Djinn to a little
bit and then after that like nothing
bayonetta and palutena hair mold and
only know he rational 150 yeah I feel ya
I feel you on that one
why is there a sandbag as an item
no no don't even think about the
smashball let's go dude
okay you're just gonna walk right and
walk right into it that worked for me
I'm not gonna complain yeah I played a
ton Hearthside I was in middle school
and Pokemon took over let's see
I was yeah I guess I was too all right
like six seventh grade somewhere in
there
honestly pokemon yellow man this just
brought me back to a blog post I wrote
years ago back when I was in the
blogging I did like my top my top games
of all time and one of them I can't
remember what number I had it but at
pokemon yellow on there mainly because
Pokemon was like when I became more than
just like a casual gamer
when I started playing like trying to do
everything in games and not just oh
let's check out this game and if we beat
it great if we don't beat it a no big
deal but like really playing games if
you know what I mean is pokemon yellow
was the game that really changed things
for me because I had a Nintendo I had a
Super Nintendo I had a Playstation it
was that what was that dude
[Music]
I don't even know what item he picked up
but I certainly did not expect to die
right there Punk and then we knock him
off that always happens dude 0% I feel
like if you come back and you kill him
without taking any damage they should
give you that those coins back any
reason for yellow who red and blue
oh no I mean I had red and blue as well
I think I actually got yellow first
though
and I think yellow was actually what did
it have that was different
of course the you could get Pikachu
right off the bat because you followed
you around but I want to say it was
actually in am I crazy it was in color
and red and blue warrant is that how
long ago we're talking
weren't red and blue Gameboy and pokemon
yellow I could be wrong about that but
there was something else that like
enhanced pokemon yellow but I had them
both and played all three of them but
yeah so when I was a kid like growing up
I mean I played games but I didn't
really play games you know what I mean I
didn't play them to completion and and
really try and see it all the way
through well I think there was something
about Pokemon being in a handheld form
factor yeah what is going on here dude
I'm not even enough to set foot on the
stage or you kidding me there was
something about the handheld form factor
though that I really like you could play
anywhere and so on my parents when we go
on trips and when we drive and just go
anywhere you know take the Gameboy and
just play play play do everything catch
all the pokemon you asked about red and
blue I had red and blue so I can do the
trade get my sisters heard gameboy color
and then trade Pokemon between them so I
could collect them all and I wouldn't
caught Mewtwo I mean I did I did
everything in that game and enjoyed it
man it was so fun and they've always
said you know Pokemon is like babies RPG
some people say it as a as an insult but
I don't view it as an insult at all I
mean for me it really was like
introduction to a it's really a whole
new world of games that I didn't know
you could play games like that that deep
and from there the rest is kind of
history that's that was the moment I I
say that I became more of a hardcore
gamer I think it may be right our side
prepare for shades of ugly green yeah
what was such an interesting oh man
the original Gameboy dude
goodbye Roy
a hook had been playing really well with
Lucario yet we have two two deaths
already that's unfortunate
yeah we're only at five point well now
six point two heading into the okay we
got greninja and then bonus stage and
then final boss greninja another Pokemon
that I have I only know because of the
Smash Brothers series oh why didn't my
parry not work there what a move he just
like cross the stage we made it halfway
across the stage with that move
not hating though still have the SNES an
accessory that lets you play gameboy
games do they make an accessory are you
talking like is this like an accessory
that's been made after the fact as I
remember the they made the Gameboy
player where you could play I think it
was GBA game gameboy advance on the
Gamecube now you had that too you're
talking about the one that Hearthside
was talking about or the gameboy player
I don't remember the SNES accessory play
gameboy games that's awesome though
giant cartridge you could put your
gameboy games in for the SNES dude
that's pretty sick so I guess Nintendo
had a history of doing that then when
they did it for the Gamecube I love my
Gamecube and I feel like it was such an
underappreciated console I go back I
have such fond memories of GameCube Kart
has a slot for gameboy games playing
with your SNES controller gotcha
wait how do we survive that how did we
survive that wouldn't believe some of
the Gameboy accessories you had
it's funny my wife still had like she's
one of those people who saves everything
I'm not gonna call her a hoarder but she
likes to save things I'm one of those
people who like get rid of it sell it
move on and that's those are the things
that I regret selling I sold like all my
old game stuff and then when she and I
were dating and I saw she had a Super
Nintendo I was like oh man this is meant
to be this is meant to be she still had
her Super Nintendo and so then when we
got married he came kind of my Super
Nintendo - Oh what did I just do
whoa Koryo has awesome recovery okay um
but in addition to the Super Nintendo
turns out she had an original NES as
well as well as her original Gameboy
like man I should have saved all this
stuff but we have hers and she had this
accessory for the Gameboy that was um I
guess it was more like a carrying case
but it was like a giant it looked like a
gameboy but it was huge like a size of a
lunch box and you carried around your
Game Boy in that and games of course it
fit all the cartridges and stuff - no no
no dude that recovery is awesome please
please no don't don't throw me off right
here let's go let's go
holy crap you had that too the nostalgia
I'll see if I can find it and pull it
out on stream one night yeah she had the
giant it was like a giant Gameboy and
there was one of the things she had that
I'm like what is this oh it was the the
mousepad
in the mouse that came with Mario Paint
for the Super Nintendo she had she still
had that like what is this man this is
awesome
Nintendo you know they were never one to
shy away from the accessories they would
always I mean they've always been
they'll make all kinds of extra
accessories the nostalgia dude that's
what the stream is all about
I feel like sharing those old stories
man cuz gaming it's just at a different
time now
I talked with Hearthside about this all
the time it's like nowadays you still
have your mouse yeah the grey plastic
that's right dude nowadays it's like all
of our epic gaming moments anything
awesome it's like it happens on stream
if it doesn't happen on a stream
most of the consoles now have share
features I guess they all do now right
switch even has it yeah you've got share
buttons you can instantly share the
video whereas when you were a kid at
least when I was a kid some of you out
there may be kids right now like what
are you talking about when we were kids
back before the internet before the
world wide web you had to share these
stories on the playground man share
these stories at sleepovers when you're
hanging out for birthday parties and
just playing games together before all
this was on the internet the next day
[Music]
she came back from that are you kidding
me dude if she wins this now there we go
welcome Rosalina welcome to the team
Rosalina and luma